you bought your co-stars Maserati here's
what happened if you want to know the
truth with Jennifer I got three Ferraris
every time I wheel it up there some guy
comes out and goes okay get that out of
here and I'm like no no this is again
this is a gift a Jennifer it's not call
him and he goes and are you looking in
the driveway
no and he goes
go out front and call me they're putting
a car in my driveway and I go what
what's happening they go Adam Sandler go
is this his car I'm supposed to watch it
and they go yeah it's for you I go okay
I call Rock and I go and I'm keeping
Adam's Card here for some reason no
that's for you we all got one I was like
what and then he goes mine's an accord
what'd you get hahaha